- Panic, panic panic...
- Is this different than how you do it?
- Yes!
(mysterious music)
- Today, I am going to be
shaving Matt's beard off.
- Yeah she is.
- I don't like shaving my face because
I have very sensitive skin
and I bleed very easily.
- Good to know.
- Okay.
- It's your nerves that
make me nervous. - Really?
- Otherwise, I'll not be nervous at all.
- (gasp) You don't trust me?
- No, I trust you.
(mumbles) What I'm worried about
is that you don't trust you.
- This could really hurt my face.
- I know, I really really like his face.
So I'm gonna really do my
best not scar it forever.
(challenging music)
- This is really cool!
- It's like finger painting.
Only, it might get a little bit lethal.
- It's not gonna get lethal.
- Your hair's so thick, I'm like here
tilt your head. - [Matt] Okay.
- I don't know if I'm hurting you or
if it's like just like coming off?
(groans)
- Does that feel terrible?
- I think you're going a little too hard.
- [Taylor] Oh really? - [Mike] Yes
- Oh (beep)
- Is that hair under your ear?
- Yes, it's everywhere.
- (giggles)
- Don't go across my neck like
you're slitting my throat!
- (laughs)
- Okay, now (mumbles)
(laughter)
- Oh, my vocal chords!
- (giggles) I'm sorry.
- (sighs) How do you...
This is exhausting!
- Why do you think I hate shaving?
- Oh no! Oh no!
- Am I bleeding?
- Did you slit my throat?
- I'm so sorry
Your Adam's Apple (mumbles)
- You cut me!
- Okay.
- (gasps)
- What, what, what, what, what...
What? - [Denisse] You're fine,
I put it there and it made this noise.
It sounded like I was
gonna tear your neck open.
- You don't know what angle
you're doing (mumbles)
You need to have a strategy.
- So I'm looking and thinking about it.
You can't like...
The artist's canvas doesn't talk back.
- I feel like I hold a
lot of power right now.
- I jumped because you're going fast.
- I love you, but please
just let me do this.
- I love you, but you're gonna kill me.
- They're gonna give me a
lifetime achievement award,
it's gonna be for shaving your face.
That's how long it's taking.
(razor scratching)
- This is like the saddest razor.
- (grunts) It's so sensitive.
- [Taylor] Is it? - [Mike] Ahh...
- I'm sorry.
- Oh no! Uhh...
- You cut me?
- Um...
- I'm bleeding open?
- Like dots, a couple of them.
- That's blood.
- (mumbles) there's like eight of them.
- Eight of them?
(exhales)
- (moans)
- Don't say that.
- I didn't say a word.
Ahh, that was really hard.
- Seriously (lips smacking)
- I was reacting to a
vicious attack there.
- It wasn't a vicious attack!
It was a loving shave.
(suspenseful music)
- You look so good!
- Does it look good?
- You look handsome
- I look handsome?
- I, I made you look really handsome.
- Thank you babe
(lips smack)
- Well, I'm never coming
back to you again, barber!
(lips smacking)
- Did I change your mind? (giggles)
- This is the worst barber
shop I've ever been too.
- I think it just made me realize
how exhausted I can be and still love him.
Does that make sense?
- [Matt] That's great!
- I feel like I look terrible.
- I think he looks beautiful,
no matter what.
- If you're just ripping skin,
you need more shaving cream.
- (mumbles)
- (mumbles) I think it's about safety.
(giggles)